welcome to this video oh that's a cool
username y YH to double O for wha wha
wha something the Chinese flag okay
what's up here let's play the Queen's
engineer with Bishop to e6 yeah Queenie
for it's not the most exciting line of
them they all play see fire but it
really is a bit boring can i play okay I
just I just do something else I wonder
if that was a good idea to do something
else okay yes c5 is the normal way to
play and move from six but it's mansion
it's boring so I wanted to try something
else but here white is better there is
no doubt unfortunately okay let's
clarify the situation down at least get
the bishop pal
a 6am it's difficult to develop this
piece let's play that very quickly and
confidently Knight to d7 s may be a
possibility and 96 okay a ticky 59 c5
it's not it's not much fun c6 maybe I
can just about play that but it's very
very shaky
Queen Jeff I still still continues to
play super quickly
Bishop CH or not no no okay start with
start with deform okay i can go d3 if I
like 96 it's also possible other than f4
is certainly an option can also flick in
Bishop c8
difficult that will be a time time issue
at the end my idea is that well Queen f3
is not really where he wants to go has
to go to h5 I guess and I'm going back f
4 C 5 f-5 Queen g5s my was my idea
yes it's got H for later Queen g5 queen
of three night back and tough but anyway
but what else is there I have to do that
yeah Queen f3 is only move here anyway
what is he doing yeah my Center looks
fantastic but here mm-hmm things are not
so fantastic however I'm a checking e5
that was one of the ideas Queen F 496 is
also why i went to d8 not to c7 I don't
know how he covers your fire if at all
still my king would always be a little
bit of a bit little bit of a problem
there I check with the Queen dismay be5
coming but happy should be several ok
let's take with the Queen that's also
intense Bishop g4
yeah Bishop g4 is actually quite awkward
he would like to play night at four but
that gives away the exchange maybe he
still wants to do that okay should have
three then maybe I also have Bishop a
six ok let's start this and maybe go
Bishop a six next for the check on the
night yeah with tempo
where are you going to e7 the night the
queen is close to being trapped it just
has a seven that you can check okay grab
them I can take g3 don't know
pushing the pawns shouldn't be bad
it's still not so clear how I am
promoting them now d 42 might be it
might be good okay I'm easily persuaded
after Bishop age three to play that
92 is a is a threat 92 rook checks d
takes rook 28 and promotes so let's jump
jump in
I can take be to hear right time morning
some some big discoveries threatening
night f4 and stuff
really you're saying that it's no
discovery because I've look f2
94 we gave to work hard to believe maybe
he's right though I won't take on f7 I
want the Queen's off here doesn't do
that if seven hang so I'm sure playing
this very badly might might still be
winning but check check check check mate
oh yeah I know yeah I that is opening
was that was really not a good idea yeah
I what I know is about this line is that
they normally go like this ikea here and
now white can do this for example and
this is quite boring and so yeah maybe
still I should do that or they can take
here that's also possible also this is a
bit a bit boring but maybe I should do
that stone I just wanted to do like
something else and I really got under
some pressure this is this is not a
great position here I believe okay he
already has a tactic funny
remarkable again this is a pawn
there's nothing no compensation
sometimes you can do something because
the Queen Ursa but there's nothing is
just a pawn yeah the opening wasn't good
I mean I had this feeling but I didn't
see this this variation yeah I'm not
sure he played all this very very
quickly if the Queen really wants to be
there the situation in the center here
is quite quite complicated you can also
consider just to go back here I'm not
sure about it c6 I have to play and now
II for ya if eyes again a move that you
played instantly but i'm not sure about
this yeah for example this is
interesting kicking in the night here
first if i go here there might be be
five yeah it's very good for wider if i
go here let me decide the fact that i
don't want to go there you might play
here and this is much much better than
with a form i think this is turning the
tables the computer switches to a black
advantage here already that's possible
it's very very tricky though to play
form c5 i think this looks fairly fairly
logical and back into the age yeah this
is important that i have this move and
the computer says or gives this as a
possible variation with about equal play
000 yeah meaning its total a total mess
yeah and here's somehow got the upper
hand but it is it is very very
complicated as I definitely could have
played better yeah here I can take g3
maybe I should have just done that I
mean I saw the move of course but I felt
her I don't know and I thought this is
pushed let's push pawns it was kind of
kind of funny that he allowed the
discovery but there is nothing great I
mean I saw this line and I didn't see
how to continue then
this is the computer says black wins
here but you don't this is a move that
or position where human is just totally
afraid yeah your king seems very open
and turn yeah but it seems to hand seems
to win the computer is always oh here
here White had a draw how just move Wow
why I here we have seven this is
possible well that would have been a
shocker Wow check yeah I'm losing
everything here and this in this
particular line so I have to go King
edge aid according to the engine rook
cheeks cheeks and now knight c6 haha I
never ever would have played that one oh
my god okay that was lucky that he
didn't come up with that I would have
been been a real shock here well I'm
kind of kind of struggling but keeping a
win well that was that was tense yeah
are not a good idea to experiment in
this opening it seems with them what I
did okay well thanks for watching